أثبت جين كيم إصابته بفيروس كورونا
قبل ثلاثة أسابيع بعد عودته من
الولايات المتحدة ، وكان في المستشفى
منذ أن أعطاه اختبار سلبي هذا الأسبوع
الأمل في أنه قد تعافى ولكن في اليوم التالي
ثبتت إصابته مرة أخرى ، يحتاج المريض
إلى سلبيتين متتاليتين.
اعتبر أنه تعافى لكن كيم يقول إنه حتى
بعد خروجه من المستشفى سوف
يعزل نفسه لمدة أسبوعين لحماية
عائلته ، أحتاج إلى العودة مرة أخرى وفي
الوقت الذي يجب على عائلتي أن تفعل نفس العزلة
مرة أخرى ، فإن ذلك يثير القلق في جميع أنحاء العالم
من حالات الاختبار الإيجابية بعد
الظهور  تعافى من
نائب مدير مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في كوريا يقول إن
هناك أربعة تفسيرات محتملة
[موسيقى]
اختبار نقل الجسيمات
أيضًا إعادة تنشيط
الزنجي أخيرًا على المستوى القابل للاكتشاف من جسيم فيروسي
يقول كوان إن الاختبارات على عائلة مكونة من
ثلاثة أفراد أثبتت نتائج جيري إيجابية قد
اكتملت بالفعل  ولا يوجد دليل
على أن الفيروس الحي لا يزال في أجسادهم
يعتقد أن بقايا الفيروس الميت
هي السابقة الأكثر احتمالا  التخطيط في هذه
المرحلة ، يقول أيضًا إنه لا يوجد
مؤشر على أن المرضى المتعافين
معديون عندما يعيدون اختبارهم إيجابيًا في
ظل عدم وجود سكرتير رئيسي.
قال إنه لم
يكن لديه أعراض لكيم ، إنها مجرد حالة
انتظار كيف تشعر في
الوقت الحالي بعد أن اجتزت الاختبارات
، أطلق عليها 19 شعرت بالإحباط ولكني الآن
أفضل بالفعل باولا هانكوك سي إن إن سيئول